right now I'm going to update iOS 10 I'm
so excited I can't believe I actually
haven't done it yet so it's coming out
officially this week and I'm uh I'm
gonna just punch right out
so let's get this update started that's
alright that's not right restart I agree
hurry up I need to go shopping I have to
go to the mall
Iowa ten it has been installed at Silla
betas not quite out yet
but this is uh this turned into sort of
an iOS 10 install in a vlog because I'm
heading to New York and I need to go
shopping I don't have any items I'm
going to be doing this show and I don't
have anything to wear I just sent Edie a
hi Edie which two else should I send
temperature centers and knows the emojis
are so big
look how big they are like that's an
apple it's a Big Apple look at this
tornado it's huge that's gonna kill me
you're like shut up
made it to the mall a lot of you guys
are probably enough question was saying
just seen how do i download iOS 10
before it's out so you go to the Apple
developer site and you set a profile you
register and then you download an
installer profile and then basically you
can just install it it's super super
simple but you might as well just wait
till it's actually out or you don't have
to wait really you can do it everyone so
far my initial thoughts just kind of
casual using it it feels a little like
it's too childish so you can drive with
like invisible ink I showed it to Jenna
you should go what's the point I'm real
simple Jenna's she's a skeptic wait
where's Bloomie's here it is yeah we'll
see I'm gonna test it out let me keep
doesn't it out while we shop how about
these shoes this look not really like
something that I am looking for to be on
a show like these sunglasses though you
can tell this shirt already is holding
it so it's basically like my dog already
got a little bit but I really like it
speaking of on-trend
I know I like them too but it's like I
feel just stupid buying a shirt with
holes in it yeah
I thought all shirt holes in my hand I
am gonna buy does anyone remember the
time in my life when I used to wear a
lot of fingerless gloves trend is back
look who we slotted in bloomingdales row
boy baby official fake crap dish old and
somebody knockoffs but the originals are
throw boy so don't even front this is
the original this is the og throw boy in
the house and you find a pair of simple
shoes with no logos simple shoes silly
that's not so simple this happened here
he it was like a shoe explosion crazy
there's the board going around from fete
snapchatter and I think I'm going to win
the award especially my current snapchat
story
service okay loading let me show you
guys
did you view it that was it you didn't
like it
and I want my war
let's talk a little more about iOS nice
shoes girl I don't even know
don't even know I'll say hi Jenna
but I want to slam
hi Jenna but I want oh yeah push
down on it and I can do all these things
I can slam it to her
I can send it loudly gently with
invisible ink but I can also send her a
screen with balloons
confetti lasers
fireworks
and shooting star
I'll send it to her with lasers
set
do you see what I'm doing I'm sending
you to my phone if you don't have iOS 10
installed that's what it says
you think it's dumb
traveling to make money because they're
going to sell pack
I'm gonna send this I'm going to slam it
I'm gonna slam this nice lamb a fox a
gentle and then I can like like her
thing
I laughed at that
be honest with you
pictures paint Center like it's kind of
like the Apple watch
[Music]
he's gonna see you oh stop
okay
yeah
laughter you own that I did just go in
your real quick real quick the new
series of LEGO minifigures you're out
and I haven't had a chance to get them
yet so
kind of time to do this right now okay
she's stressed out don't you have a
flight in like 10 hours if you I'm
getting picked up at 6:30
beautiful pup oh god something just
happened go out one I score a
millionaire my tie my hair so stressed
out let's just not do it let's go home
they're back from our little shopping
and iOS 10 excursion I basically found
nothing so I have no idea what I'm gonna
wear for the shoot but hopefully I don't
know I find something you guys recall
not too long ago I actually got rid of
almost all of my clothes so really the
only things that I saved were yoga pants
some jeans and workout clothes so a
problem to end this vlog I guess would
give you my sort of initial thoughts of
iOS 10 I think it's cool I mean at some
point we're running out of things that
are new and innovative I just feel like
these additions are strange it's I mean
it's cool it's it's kind of gimmicky not
really sure how often I'm gonna be
slamming text and sending invisible ink
or random things like that especially
the screen things I feel like that's
kind of cheap that's just my thought I
feel like I'm just becoming so jaded
with technology it's very hard to
impress us at this point when I go
because it's 11 o'clock right now and I
have three videos to edit and upload and
I have to get up at 5:00 a.m. that's
going to be really fun I can't wait to
be great most you guys in New York right
now I'm off to go play Monopoly
that is my favorite board game ever